qu'est ce qui s'est passé sur blood sur
twitter et sur install les chéris hier
benjamin castaldi avait posté une vidéo
dans laquelle vous pousser un coup de
gueule à 30 ans n'avait pas apprécié les
propos tenus par line renaud qui a
évoqué votre grand mère simone signoret
et la cafal vcast à savoir si je
découvre ce matin
line renaud pour plusieurs demeurant
beaucoup de respect
des oranges sur ma mère et je commence à
être sérieusement lasser
parce que ces personnes qui attaquent
très ce sens qu'ils sont plus là c'est
pas loin qu'on soit élargi le regina
génocide et qu'il plus tôt dans leur vie
anciens en sorte que le monde aille
mieux vaut ça crée du temps pour les
autres et offrir du bonheur et à défaut
de bonheur proposer un talent qui a été
parfois et souvent partager et apprécier
foutez la paix à tous ceux qui sont plus
là foutez la paix à tony il souhaitait
la paix à ma grand mère et tout est là
qu est ce qui est plus la chance pouvoir
se défendre
ça commence sérieusement à me casser les
couilles voilà à bon entendeur salut
[Applaudissements]
alors la nuit au look qui s'est confié
dans paris-match causal avait déclaré je
fais la perte de temps en temps mais je
ne commence pas à boire de l'alcool au
réveil comme simone signoret donc c'est
votre credo la première l'idée 10 heures
du matin tremper ses croissants dans le
pastis à la colombe d'or et la clé dans
une colère est ce que vous avez eu ni
noël et simple indiquant bien encore
plus franchement je la connais depuis
elle m'a vu naître quasiment c'est
dommage mais mais qui ne vous a pas
bougé la balle aurait valu à la
naissance mon frère pour la circoncision
il paraît que celle qu'il aurait parait
que c'est que de killer qui l'a appelé
plus tôt plutôt très gentil et j'ai pas
aimé cette attaque traîtresse que vous
l'avez eue
j'ai alors on s'est croisé au téléphone
on sait pas eu directement mais je sais
qu'elle est à quai les embêter qu'elle
me voilà qu'elle veut pas dire dire du
mal et moi franchement ça va vraiment
blessé c'était ma grand mère et/ou pas
qu'on dise que ma grand-mère avait du
reste on est entré dans un style dans un
croissant à 10 heures du matin à sablé
cents us un peu humiliant et c'est vrai
que dans les artistes qui ont jalonné le
siècle dernier que c'est quand même une
des femmes qui fait le plus pour les
autres qui a fait des beaux films ça m'a
fait chier voilà vous n'en voulait plus
aller en maintenant j'en veux pas à
lille parce que voilà mais c'est
vraiment ça m'a dit non non vous ne
voulez plus non ça mais ça m'a vraiment
fait de la peine non je vous dis
franchement ça mais ça m'a peiné ça me
fait d'appoint que j'ai pas figé mais en
panne parce que c'est ma grand-mère et
c'est normal et voilà donc c'est pas
envie qu'on dise du mal pour toute la
fin voilà mon benji voilà mais c'est
bien vous avez bien fait de réagir
oui madame moi ce que je pense c'est que
pour l'excuser on peut se dire qu'elle a
peut-être plus toute sa tête
à 6-6 et non pas les renault
jamais lyon du bien des gens vous mettra
bien les choses ainsi mais chanter aussi
grade succès je me dis qu'elle achète
non mais c'est pas méchant la raconter
une anecdote de sécurité c'est comme
quand on dirait bien c'est bon c'est bon
merci d arreter pas vrai surtout madame
c'est pas vrai non
on aimerait doit effectivement adam est
temps d'en savoir un peu mais je savais
pas des décroissants corps on m'a très
bien alors ce n'était pas des
croissances et les chouquettes ce n'est
pas du passé c'était le whisky merci